NATHAN MARTZ: I'm Nathan.
I'm the lead product
manager for developers
on Tango and Daydream.
And today, I get to talk
to you about something
that is super awesome--
at least I think it is--
and that is immersive computing.
Immersive computing is a family
of very related technologies
that we believe is
going to revolutionize
how people interact
with information
and experience the world.
With VR, we could actually
take people from the world
that they live in-- there we go.
We can actually take people
from the world they live in
into unfamiliar new worlds.
We can make them feel physically
present in new places,
both real and imaginary.
With AR, we can actually
bring the world of information
into our own.
We can enhance with
information and interactivity
the actual objects
and environments
we find ourselves in.
Both of these together are
incredibly powerful ways
of enhancing and
expanding the way
that we interact with the world.
And of course, at
Google, we think
this is amazing, because our
mission is about interactivity
and about information.
We think about our mission
statement-- organizing
the world's information,
making it universally
accessible and useful.
And that's why when
we think about VR
and AR and immersive
computing, we
know that VR is going
to make our ability
to be surrounded by it, to
access information incredibly
more immersive.
And AR is going to make
the information that we're
surrounded by--
sensors from our phones
and from the internet of things,
from the data sources that we
have about our
products and our users,
and the physical objects
that surround us--
and make all of that
dramatically more
useful and interactive.
At Google, we also think a
lot, I think, about scale,
like all of you do.
We want to maximize our
reach and our impact.
And we believe
that fundamentally,
scale and immersive
computing is going
to come from mobile
computing form factors.
So already today,
there's no surprise,
there's billions
more smartphones
in the world than PCs.
People have spoken, and they
say the future is mobile.
And so what you'll
see is everything
that we're doing around
immersive computing
will be built around
mobile form factors.
So today, I'm going
to talk to you
about two platforms, two
products specifically,
the first of which is
Daydream, our platform
for mobile virtual
reality, and Tango
for mobile augmented reality.
And I think this is a
great time, actually,
to be doing immersive
computing work,
because this stuff is
finally becoming real.
Just a few weeks ago,
we launched the Pixel,
which is the first
Daydream Ready
phone in the world,
the first one that
embodies our vision for what's
possible in VR on your phone.
And just a couple
of days ago, Lenovo
released the Phab 2 Pro,
which is the very first
Tango-ready phone in the world.
So this technology
is not theoretical.
It's not abstract.
You can go to a Best
Buy or the Google store
and get these devices
now and actually
experience for yourself
virtual reality
and augmented reality
available on your phone.
So we'll dive into both of
these platforms in a little more
detail so that you can
understand the specifics
and the opportunities.
With Daydream, we're talking
about virtual reality.
And the challenge
with VR is you're
creating a sense of
presence for the user.
That requires you to have
hardware and software that work
perfectly with one another.
When somebody takes their
phone and puts it in the viewer
and straps it on
their head, you're
teleporting them somewhere else.
You're creating a
synthetic sense of reality.
And when it's flawless,
it's transformative.
And when it's not, it's
often not that awesome.
And so we've been
working very carefully
to design the hardware, the
Pixel phone, and the viewer,
and all the software,
like Android N,
to work well to
be perfect for VR.
And for months and
months, my team
has been obsessing over the
details of these platforms,
making sure that the
phones are actually
ready to deliver amazing VR
experiences, that our viewer is
lightweight and comfortable,
that it has a controller
that you can interact with.
But for us, we think
it's honestly not
good enough to build
something that's great.
We want as many
people in the world
to experience VR as possible.
And so we've done
the really hard work
to actually make the viewer and
controller available for a very
affordable price point.
And also, they're sold together.
So as a developer, you can
know exactly what input
every single Daydream
user is going to have
when they launch your app.
We know that fragmentation
is a big concern
for a lot of
developers, and we're
making sure that that's
not a problem on Daydream.
Also, of course, like I
said, this stuff really
matters when it's real,
when you go to a store
and buy it and take it home
and experience it for yourself.
And Daydream View
is actually going
to be available in stores
in just a few days, a week
from today, on November 10,
which is also super, super
exciting.
So the foundation of Daydream
is, of course, the phone.
All the sensors are in the phone
that you use for the device.
But Daydream is not about a
specific phone like the Pixel
or only phones made by Google.
Like I said, we
believe in scale,
and scale is going
to mean the way
that Android does it, which is
do partnerships and other OEMs.
And so it's actually a
standard called Daydream ready.
And the Daydream-ready
certification
is something that we actually
work directly with OEMs
to make sure that every phone
that's tagged Daydream-ready
is actually going
to be great for VR.
That means things
like certifying
that there's low persistence
displays, high compute SOCs,
and accurate low latency
sensors on the device.
This way, as a
developer, you know
that every Daydream-ready phone
will run your app really well.
And for consumers,
they know that when
they buy a Daydream-ready
phone, the entire catalog
is going to work great on it.
Also, every
Daydream-ready phone is
running Android N, which is
our first version of Android
actually optimized
to be great at VR.
And we've done some really
fundamental innovations.
We've done things like
Sustained Performance Mode.
So we actually manage
the SOC inside the phone.
We basically have different
power management in VR
to balance performance
and run time.
We've got very
sophisticated head tracking
that fuses all of the sensors
on the device to figure out
where you're looking
in space very,
very accurately and
at very low latency.
But of course, it's
still your phone.
And sometimes, you
get notifications.
You get phone calls.
And so we've taken core Android
System UI and made it VR aware.
So if you get a call
while you're in VR,
you can actually stay in
VR and decide for yourself
whether you want to
answer that call or not.
So the phone is great.
But with just a
phone, it's not VR.
It's a phone.
And to be transformative,
we need a viewer
that lets you see
the world in 3D
and a controller that
lets you interact with it.
And that's what Daydream
View is all about.
On the viewer, it's
actually very simple.
It's electronically inert, which
means that all of the smarts
are in the phone itself.
And the job of the viewer is
to be as comfortable as humanly
possible.
We've actually tried
to take a lot of cues
from apparel, from soft goods.
If you look at a
lot of high tech VR,
they're inspired more by
gadgets, by DVD players
and consoles.
But nobody wears
electronics on your body.
Nobody wants to put a
DVD player on their face.
So we try to think about
for a thing that you wear,
let's design it in the same
way, to be made of fabric,
soft and approachable.
The controller looks
actually pretty simple,
but it's honestly
really expressive.
And there's a
challenge in VR, which
is when you have
a controller, you
need to be able to
use it blindfolded.
You're wearing a viewer.
And so you need a
controller that's
both accessible for
users, that they
can operate without
looking at their hands,
but expressive for developers.
And so we have a few
different surfaces.
The key is a clickable touchpad.
It's an analog touchpad that
supports touch and click
separately.
There's an app button
that's up to you
to do whatever you want
with and a Home button
that we reserve for key
actions, like taking
the user from your app
back to Daydream Home.
Most critically, though,
this is a motion controller.
It has a 9-axis IMU that can
give you very, very accurate 3D
orientation.
And you can use that the way you
would a Wiimote on a console,
actually give people a live
sense of hand presence.
You can map virtual objects
to what the real controller is
doing, and people will feel
a very powerful connection
of how the virtual
world is connected
to their physical actions.
So all of that is enough to
get you from the real world
into VR.
But for us, the platform
is about-- it actually
has to extend past
that entry point.
And we know that
for most of you,
you want to actually not
just make great software.
You want to make a living.
You have businesses to run.
And so for us, we've been
very focused on both discovery
and monetization.
The screen behind me here is
what's called Daydream Home.
This is the first
place that every user
goes when they put their viewer
into the headset and step
into VR.
The top three big tiles, they're
called discovery windows.
They are surfaces where we
curate and expose the best
original content for Daydream.
We know that early
adopters of VR
are going to be extremely
hungry for new content,
and we want to surface that
as often and as prominently
as possible.
The cool thing is that we
actually can leverage deep
linking in these
discovery windows,
not just to promote new
apps, but new experiences
within existing apps.
So if you're building
a platform, a service,
and you have new content
coming in all the time,
we can actually service
that new content, not just
the launch of the
platform itself.
So that's discovery.
It helps get people
exposed to the best of what
we have to offer.
But monetization is
really important as well.
So we've brought, actually,
with the launch of Daydream,
the Play Store into VR so
users can browse for content,
check out collections,
buy apps, and install them
all without leaving VR.
It's an incredibly
easy, low-friction way
for people to find new content.
Of course, that's awesome,
but we know that many of you
have whole businesses
built on selling goods,
on transacting
within applications,
not selling premium
goods up front.
And so we're actually
launching with in-app purchases
or in-app billing day and date
with the launch of Daydream.
So whether you're a freemium
developer or a premium
developer or
somewhere in between,
you can bring your content
and your business model
into VR right out of the gate.
And for me, this is
all super exciting.
But nothing really speaks to
the power of the platform more
than what developers are
already creating for it.
So I think we'll check out a
video that shows exactly that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
All right.
Well, that gives you a sense
of what Daydream is all about.
And now I'm going
to switch gears,
and I'm going to talk
about Tango, which is
our AR technology and platform.
And where Daydream's core
technological challenge
and opportunity
for innovation is
about creating a
sense of presence,
taking people from
the real world
and helping them teleport
to somewhere else,
Tango is all about basically
taking the computers
that we have in our
pocket and teaching
them to see the world
the same way that we do.
And if you think
about our phones,
we have them with us everywhere.
And they have some
amazing sensors in them.
They have accelerometers and
gyro and GPS and cameras.
But they still
don't fundamentally
think of the world or see it and
understand it to the same level
that humans do.
For example, if you take a
look at this coffee table here,
it's not just a bunch of pixels.
As humans, we look
at it, and we know
that there's important
features, that there
are edges that are sharp
and corners that we
might bump into.
We know that some
sides are flat,
that it has a top and a bottom.
We know that that object
doesn't just exist in isolation.
We know that there are
other objects around that,
that that vase is on
top of the coffee table,
that the coffee table
is near the sofa.
And in fact, we know
not just about objects
and their relationship.
We think about spaces.
We think about how this
coffee table is in a room,
and that room has
many things in it.
And as you start to think
about and understand a space,
you can actually consider not
just the physical objects,
but what might also be there.
You can imagine that if
this family had a baby,
they might add some
additional objects.
In fact, it's not just
about what might be there.
It's about how the
objects behave,
that there are things like
door knobs and light switches
that are interactive
that have special meaning
and special functionality in
the context of that space.
And Tango is all
about enabling phones
to understand the world
exactly like we do,
in a structured
and deep fashion.
And there's really
three technologies
that allow us to do that.
The first is motion tracking.
There is depth perception
and area learning.
And these are the pillars that
Tango has built on top of.
So with motion
tracking, it's all
about helping the
phone understand where
it is in space, both its
position and orientation
as you move around.
And you might think,
well I have GPS.
Doesn't that already
give me position?
I've got a gyro
and accelerometer.
Doesn't that give
me orientation?
Well, they do, but
they're very coarse.
GPS is accurate to
centimeters or meters
and worse when you're indoors.
The gyros have drift over time.
But Tango fuses all
of that and uses
a technology called
visual inertial odometry
to get very, very precise
estimates of exactly where it
is in space.
And you can see examples of the
360, 3D movement all the time--
super precise,
super low latency.
But we also want to
understand the world
that the device interacts in--
not just where it is in space,
but what the outside
world looks like.
And that's where you
get to depth perception.
Depth perception allows
us to actually understand
the 3D nature of the world.
We can tell you that
some objects are close
and some objects are far.
We can tell you that walls
are flat and vertical
and floors are flat
and horizontal,
and some things are
not flat at all.
And when you combine
depth perception
with motion tracking,
you can actually
build a very
detailed, accurate map
of the world, the phone's
sense of where it is in space
and where space is around it.
But unfortunately, with
just those two things,
you've got to build a map,
and then you leave the app,
and we've lost it.
So that's where area
learning comes in.
Area earning allows us
to not just build up
a map of the world, but
to remember it over time,
and not just remember the world,
but to share maps across users.
So if somebody has mapped an
area and been there before,
other users can benefit
from that information.
And when you combine motion
tracking and depth perception
and area learning, you can
get some incredibly powerful
experiences.
You can actually build
a very precise measuring
tape using your phone
and its touch screen.
You never have to carry
a measuring tape again,
just like phones
have already replaced
flashlights for most people.
If you're a commerce
app, you can actually
have people look
at a good and see
how it's going to look in
their real space, size, scale,
and lighting before they've
ever made the purchase.
And you're going to
hear more about that
later this afternoon.
Of course, for gaming,
augmented reality is awesome.
You can have virtual pets that
inhabit the same world you do
or gaming that
actually interacts
with the physical objects
and dynamically responds
to the real world environment
you find yourself in.
And last, you can explore
your world more fully.
There's everything from highly
precise indoor navigation
to enhanced learning, to
actually augmenting the objects
around us with additional
information and interactivity.
And for me, these are incredibly
exciting opportunities.
And I hope that
together, I've given you
an idea of the opportunity in
immersive computing in both VR
through Daydream
and AR for Tango.
And although these things may
sound very exotic and crazy,
the foundations are actually
incredibly familiar to you
as developers.
Both Daydream and Tango are
built on top of Android.
And Android is, of course, the
foundation for both of them.
We have native C
NDKs and Java SDKs
for both Daydream and Tango.
So actually, enhancing
your existing apps
with either AR or VR is going
to be super straightforward
if you're a native
Android developer today.
And of course, with Android,
you get Google Play.
And like you saw, we've
integrated everything
from the stores to IEP deeply
into both Tango and Daydream
so you can leverage all
of the transactions,
the payments in
dozens of countries,
all of the user analytics and
customer engagement features.
All of that familiar
and powerful toolset
is available for you
today in AR and VR.
We know that many of you,
if you're doing 3D already,
you're maybe using a game
engine like Unity or Unreal.
And we've built deep
partnerships with both Epic,
the maker of Unreal, and
with Unity for first class
native support for both
Tango and Daydream.
And that means that if you're
using these game engines,
you'll get first class,
super easy to use,
very high performance AR and VR
with both of these world class
game engines.
I hope all of this has given
you a sense of the potential,
the vision, the
scale and the impact
that immersive computing
is going to have.
If you want to know
more, if you want
to be a developer for Daydream
or Tango, or hopefully both,
check them out online.
There are developer
resources and tons more
information available for you.
We can't wait to
see what you make.
Thank you so much for your time.
[APPLAUSE]